hey guys how's it going so today we're
going to be chatting about something
that I've had in my possession for like
week because a lot of you guys know one
of the biggest things that was a
disappointment was the new MacBook is
the charger is now just straight-up USB
see previous maxbox you had this thing
called lag safe which is actually quite
funny a lot of people didn't know that
that was because it was magnetic I know
I think I made mention of that and I was
actually going to surprised how many
people in the comments really well I
guess that doesn't make sense so it's
that if you bumped your computer
great tripped over the charging cable
you wouldn't completely entirely lose
your computer to the floor
so far not on absolutely everything I
have yet to have that happen to me I
though oh god I'm putting it out there
the universe I'm sorry I have not had
very good Apple lost shattered phones
away sister bought her back books stolen
so this is the Griffin breakaway cable
it can also be used on USB seafoam
basically just turned your USB CH into
Max's that's why I can't never return
anything so there's two ends on this
little guy there's one that has the
little MagSafe USB see end you'll have
this little USB C dongle which you can
just put into your computer does it work
yes do you need it no do you want it
probably okay well right tables kind of
stitched though I feel like most of the
USBC cables are so the upside is this
will save your computer you happen to
trip over it the downside is you leave
it and if you lose this magnetic little
dongle then good luck
[Music]
it's not that pretty good actually no
matter which way you pull it it's coming
off okay like that game where you pick
up the fish magnetic fish does anybody
play the game when you're younger or now
oh yeah last night ah ah good quality
cool well I don't really have anything
else to say I mean it's a magnetic USB C
cable so what else can I tell you well
we're going to Amazon it is $30 they
drop the price it used to be
$39.99 which is probably what I pay it
because I ordered it so long ago I liked
it a lot and I'm probably going to
travel with it and stay tuned for how
long will it take Justine to lose this
episode that will probably be coming out
that will make a video about it stay
tuned on Twitter thank you guys so much
for watching let me know in the comments
below if there's anything else that you
think I should check out or you'd like
me to check out or even let me know
something that you absolutely hate and
you think I should check it out because
I feel like I always do positive reviews
I don't necessarily like to review
things if I don't like it so I feel like
in 2017 I think I want to show you guys
some things that I hate I don't hate
maybe it's just something that
disappointed you maybe you expected it
to do something and it didn't I don't
know
I'm up for suggestions I'll see you guys
later bye
boy it's really good they hope this is
backlit with still stop-motion what
you're so stupid
these are sold off playing call of duty